bonsoir franck poupeau merci d'être avec
nous en direct par téléphone sur rtl
france c'est donc jour de vote
aujourd'hui en bolivie jusqu'ici comment
se déroulent les élections à votre
connaissance
écoutez pellicule de soi une opinion
puisque les jours d'élection il ya ce
qu'on appelle la xk c'est une ancienne
fois on consomme pas d'alcool mais en
plus on peut pas se détacher de ce que
j'ai vu à santa cruz dans un autre
bureau autour de douchy se déroule
plutôt pas mal
par contre il n'y a pas d'incident à des
végétations à la base et avec davy
d'amendé déjà des versions controversé
le maire accusant le prière électorale
de la pas d'être famille du mas alors qu
en fait d'après les cas ménages que j'ai
se sont beaucoup plus que défense de
l'ordre qui impose des mesures
sanitaires entre candy mail secours pour
un peu dissuader des gens d'entrer voter
oui pardon jonathan ya pas deux ni trois
n'y a pas de 2,2 choses très sérieuses
ou des observateurs aussi de se
plaignent d'être un frein en tout cas
dans leur mission on se souvient
évidemment des élections ou evo morales
avait dû partir justement parce que ses
observateurs avaient qualifié de fraude
les dernières élections c'est aussi une
des données à surveiller le problème
c'est que comme l'embellie un d'élection
c'est encore l'organisation des états
américains qui les présente avec ferveur
au chat de mission sur les mêmes
il ya eu des petits incidents sur
l'arrivée de députés argentins l'alto
voilà après je ne sais pas si la
présence d'observateurs garantie quoi
que ce soit étant donné leur faible
nombre dans l'ensemble est aussi le ce
que bon bah nan la stratégie du
gouvernement est clairement décidé de se
mettre de la confusion pour faire face à
une éventuelle victoire du mas et ont
comme yann guichard c'est oui alors le
savent c'est qui apparemment est en tête
en tout cas dans les sondages certains
disent que il
l'incarnation du du miracle économique
on a entendu des boliviens qui va me
sortir de cette crise politique mais
aussi de cette crise économique
écoutez il a été quasiment plus temps
effectivement musée économique avec des
politiques au bâtiment de contrôle des
devises de contrôle de la dette
il a plutôt stabilité dans le pays et
ses concepts pas mal de gens qui étaient
indécis sont plutôt enclins à revenir
vers vers lui étant données la gestion
on va dire que pour le moins
catastrophique qui a été fait c'est
aussi bien sur le plan économique
politique ou sanitaire de la bolivie
depuis un an à peu près et j'imagine
comme dans beaucoup de pays cette crise
sanitaire qui a dû exacerbée en tout cas
les problèmes économiques
écoutez je crois qu'il faut il y voir ça
de façon différenciée dans certaines
régions comme santa croce sur son onze
sont pas trop trop les effets de la
crise les secteurs et communique le
principaux l'agro industrie le bâtiment
se portent apparemment à merveille à
contre tous les secteurs informels tous
les secteurs populaires que ce soit
santa cruz ou dans les départements
multiples anneaux comme a pas un poteau
6e ont extrêmement souffert il ya
vraiment des mesures à la hauteur pour
pour essayer de soutenir les ménages en
difficulté sur qui visaient des marchés
de l'économie informelle et du coup ça a
une conséquence victor à dire que le
match est stabilisée depuis quelques
mois malgré le report des élections
c'est celle du député quoi est ce report
même action tu es encore l'ancrage à mon
avis du mas dans les couches populaires
d'une peur très forte c'est aujourd'hui
d'aidé du gouvernement est en tout cas
de situation le plus radical que de voir
un retour des levées de l'ancien parti
pour les chiffres la clé aussi de ce
scrutin ce sont les jeunes m'a écouté
mais comme il n'y a pas trop de délais
mans 2-2
d'évaluation c'est un peu compliqué à
dire on a effectivement d'un côté on
peut penser qu'il y a des imaginations
qui n'ont pas connu les combats sociaux
d'un 2000 qui se massent socialiser par
la politique
en tout cas vers la politique telle que
les organisations sociales
traditionnelles les syndicats ou
incertaine certaines organisations
indigènes mais de les porter maintenant
comme elle jeunes ils sont aussi soumis
aux effets de la crise qui est éventé
donc on réussit à créer c'est difficile
de dire ce qu'ils veulent être rééduqués
évidemment l'enjeu de ce scrutin c'est
de sortir de la crise politique vous
pensez que ce sera possible c'est vrai
que c'est un peu tôt pour le dire
puisqu'il y aura un deuxième tour mais
on s'achemine vers une sortie de crise
politique selon vous m'écoutez de la
culture pour l'instant puisque il
consulte affirme que qu'une victoire de
2000 faire fait possible au premier tour
rien il faut que les plus de 40 % des
voix et plus de 10 % d'écart il ya
beaucoup de bruits qui circulent comme
quoi
comme quoi les l'année des fractions les
plus radicales et une extrême de la
droite au pouvoir serait prête à
intervenir par la force et à semer la
confusion pour essayer de noms célèbres
ou bien ça mais l'élection ou bien de
provoquer un autre coup de force ou un
autre coup d'état
il est temps qu'il faut mais d'un autre
côté le match lui-même qu'on accuse
beaucoup de semer le chaos
il ya eu des images assez marquante de
boutiques fermées à la base par peur que
ces militants décembre mettre le bazar
le mas via son porte parole toutes les
banques a notamment mêmes evo morales en
argentine ont affirmé qu'il respecterait
les résultats des élections
donc non c'est pas trop ça m'a en tout
cas la stratégie du chaos
combien beaucoup plus aux factions les
plus radicales du gouvernement qui ne
veulent pas lâcher le pouvoir
coma qui est en position avantageuse en
tout cas pas au premier tour et qui n'a
pas du tout intérêt à ce qu'il y ait des
débordements ou des incidents et de ce
que vous nous dites avec les entraves et
la crise sanitaire on peut s'attendre
peut-être à une forte abstention
d'écouté je pense pas je pense pas je
crois qu'au contraire les tonnages que
j'ai eu moi dans l'altiplano des andes
dans le monde rural
en tout cas il y avait une très très
forte mobilisation peut-être la mise à
l'écart d'evo morales at elle un peu
apaiser les choses en plus et
remobiliser les bases autour du parti
autour d'une cause autour d'un homme en
milieu urbain il ya quand même pas mal
de soucis apparemment dans certains
grands centres pour que tout le monde
vote mais au contraire les files
d'attentes montre qu'il n'y a pas du
tout une démobilisation et qu' il ya une
grosse au contraire il ya un gros
engagement de pas mal de citoyens pour
essayer de sauver leur peuple et leur
bois les élections merci beaucoup on va
suivre évidemment à l'issue de ce
scrutin merci franck poupeau d'avoir
répondu ce soir en direct sur arte
france à nos questions